[Music]
and mistakes were made news oh it's so
life is all about mistakes I don't make
mistakes I make life lessons I knew how
to make this I thought you guys oh sorry
I just meant you were the mistake my mom
does it make mistakes my brother was but
no this was like he was planning you
were the mistake no he actually was not
planning he was a mistake yes well that
sucks for him yeah you there's no
mistakes in life I was not a mistake my
parents tried to abort me no I know what
mistake it's just that during that time
my parents were so poor they weren't
sure that they could afford another
child dude it wasn't supposed to happen
like try it on board but then the pills
didn't work no the enemy
they had to make a choice they were like
am I gonna we're gonna keep this kid are
we gonna not have this child because we
were [ __ ] dirt poor dad and punch
hard enough huh yeah so he thinks what
is happening right now what was the
method they chose the kimchi overdose
yeah so my mom was like legitimate like
scared that she couldn't they wanted me
but they were fed that they couldn't
afford because like they were going
through such hard times and so they
decide to keep me and that's why they
call me the blessing David it wasn't
supposed to turn out like this I know
that's why I look ruining your jokes
they aborted my brother whoa damn and it
worked
they went all the way through older
younger younger cuz my parents have a
rocky relationship and then they're like
I don't know I don't know then they're
like nah let's get rid of a guy
how'd you know we know it's a brother
yeah there was a ultrasound on my TV
growing up but this is another brother
there's hella pictures of me holding my
mom's head okay I never see the question
how do you guys know it's Jen maternity
clothes so it was already big yeah she's
wearing maternity clothes and I held are
you sure it's not a miscarriage they
told me they said the second one was
aborted and the third one was a
miscarriage Bob told me specifically the
second one was gone and then they tried
it again and they lost that one yeah see
that I could turn anything dark yeah we
never a second question that sorry I
feel
curious I wanted to know more submitted
by Bart's tiny nipples watch where are
they I don't see them that would have
been there would have been so many more
of these that's so crazy how many more
actual nipple is bigger than the areola
areola yeah it's like a chocolate chip
Papa John's founder John Schnatter god
that's just weird named John SH what's
the matter with you John shut matter now
is now saying that resigning was a
mistake are they running the business to
the ground huh are they running the
business to the ground the team are they
running it to the ground old lady that
keeps on trying to [ __ ] get her point
across because tip has so much earwax
I never always listening for you is
there sugar in the tea worse
use the words you know what that means
who's the word he's listening to you but
he on purpose he does not respond back
to you when she twin she tells us
something I always catch cuz we have
communication gonna get to the ground
start tapping that bottle again me and
TIFF are always communicating are they
running it to the ground
Apple anything Ethel okay remember when
Papa John Santa racist n-word yes that's
why I forgot about that and then later
on he said he was pressured into saying
it well why did he say no no okay so he
said it because it was a employee like
sensitivity training I'll tell you why
so he was talking to this PR company and
they were trying to like make him look
better after this whole
she said oh it was after the whole NFL
statement so he said that the because of
the protests they're bringing down sales
in Pappajohn that's what he first said
and then that [ __ ] I just can we
backtrack a little bit cuz I'm not sure
what's going on when did he say the
n-word and why it was back in November
2017 but he's a change man last year
when he said the n-word so it was
because of the five-dollar special n
words no this is what he said I'm trying
to like picture what the commercial yeah
what's the context right like hey this
Papa John's love my pizza everybody was
like that would have been cool though
more than that oh [ __ ] I do the whole
NFL thing was like I said he said that
they're hurting their sales because of
the NFL thing for them so people already
started seeing him as a racist or
whatever because of that so that's when
he was on a phone call with this this
company called laundry service and he a
bubble he said on the phone call he said
quote Colonel Sanders called blacks and
words and he never received backlash
that's what he was pretty much saying so
that was a context of that and so now
that the owner of laundry service he
called to terminate the contract with
Papa John's because of that comment so
laundry service no longer wanted to work
with Papa John's after you said that
yeah that's where the scan that's where
the scandal began because those are the
phonies that use the word
that's what do you think but then so
then that's why he had to resign because
he used it and then there was all this
big controversy so then now this is the
follow-up but then he also said that he
was pressured into saying it where was
this pressure from I think you I don't
read that I don't know about that either
I never read that part I just thought
you always like what if he was just
repeating some of his favorite DMX
lyrics he is from the east coast
you have comparing Colonel Sanders to
like him was a real person as a
character no he's a real person you like
legit made that chicken yeah yes so
that's what happened and then now Papa
John's is saying I should have never
resigned the company like they failed to
do their own investigation like it was
taken out
texe I'm not a racist I like I did use
that word but not as a racial you should
have been like [ __ ]
of course I'm not racist like a lot of
people say racist words but they're not
racist look at JK news that's what you
should have said oh yeah and they
sponsored us attention and they know
we're suffering because he's getting on
this Beca oh yeah all you had to say is
yo that garlic butter though yep what
what about that what about that I have
literally never heard or seen anyone
order pizza from Papa John's we only
dealt religiously that garlic butter yup
do you remember when it first came out
it was so good when it first came out to
the west coast I was like everybody
wanted this thing is it that good that's
not Domino's or piece of hype around it
yeah and then I ate I was like oh this
is gourmet yeah it was supposed to be
like fast food pizza that wasn't fast
food Pizza yeah okay it's like it's like
Gore met [ __ ] you know and I ate it that
[ __ ] and I was like this is so different
from the greasy pizza hutt huh and then
I would take the garlic butter we would
just actually put it all over the pizza
oh yeah I've only tried it once and it
was very forgettable
yeah I think this is our younger self
though this is our seven-year old selves
now I like that thin crust [ __ ] from the
fancy places is delicious I like fashion
yeah I just don't like it when they only
put a dot of cheese on it and it's like
80% tomato sauce that makes me mad oh I
hate that I want more shoes and yeah
every time I think of Papa John I think
of he's had some weird plastic surgery
yeah well he has a Botox huh they
removed like his face from everything
why is he looking like wannabe Tony
Danza and [ __ ] I know he has eyeliner on
yeah
I don't like this races asked picture
too [ __ ] Asian eyes get the [ __ ] out
of here at that [ __ ]
very like a [ __ ] ton of eyelashes yeah
that guy he looks like a Vegas performer
he died like that that Neil Diamond is
50 trying to look like he's 20 yeah yeah
all the filler it's all the fillers and
were just Neil Diamond no neon Las Vegas
no no if he looks like he can be a mr.
loss what's his name it's not Neil
Diamond that race the restaurant the
race to race you're at that race from in
the restaurant yellow fever still open
yeah I saw I saw it the other day it's
in Torrance area I was honest I was like
oh that's where it is it looks good what
yellow fever you want to go when you
don't want to support it because there's
too much like controversy around if I
might actually look good though I'm
gonna do it just pose meets it you know
what I support it as long as it's not
tied to pedophilia if the food's not
tied to pedophilia I'll support the [ __ ]
out of you you don't need some way
anymore they could [ __ ] I've never
liked some boys dropped him with the
quickness but then yeah they he didn't
cook it so it's okay
I always feel like the food is the
energy is transferred through the food
like if there's an angry cook he [ __ ]
up the food you eat that [ __ ] you get
sad you [ __ ] feel it yeah then I'm
gonna start liking children or something
I don't know but then none of so the
thing is every time my when I when I
worked at a restaurant every time my
cooks were [ __ ] pissed from losing
gambling money there who'd always tasted
like [ __ ] and then well when they were
up there food was good so then that's
when I started feeling it like oh [ __ ]
so when I go to these cafes and whatever
I just like man this guy [ __ ] lost
his Sportsbet or something the food
tastes like [ __ ] like they don't care
about life you know somebody stubbed his
toe or something I can kind of agree
with that Mexicans have this saying that
the food's really really spicy they just
call the cook like damn you must have
been really [ __ ] pissed off yeah yeah
I think yeah so if the cook was let's
say he was amazing cook but he was a
ex-convict murderer that's okay you know
some people call it murder some people
call it warrior some people I don't know
like he did his dirt but the food is
great cuz he's out of prison and he
loved
I was watching this thing uh what's his
name his name is Mike Perry from the UFC
and him and this guy tyron woodley they
were doing that Instagram FaceTime thing
and then Mike Perry dropped the damn
bomb yeah he's a white dude but he grew
up in Florida with all black book title
Woodley just like it's gonna glaze over
because he they care and so it was like
controversial how dare he like say that
[ __ ] he goes his response was [ __ ]
gangsters [ __ ] talking with Lynch I
would they like they're like so I guess
like in the comments somebody was asking
and it's like well what do you feel
about people who say you can't say the
word he goes I think I'm cool cuz I know
you about it that's what I would would
Lee said right he goes ain't gonna do
[ __ ] white he's a white dude but he's
like he like grew up wrong like yeah
boertie and so like you know he's used
to saying that word consistently yeah
you know but the tire would that he was
cool with it you know he's black dude
and it was just funny like he's
responsible I ain't gonna do [ __ ] which
is highly true because he'd kick your
[ __ ] ass yeah it's like that asian
doing it that owns or that worked in a
liquor store Oh square yeah who's what
you gon do me yeah no one's gonna do
[ __ ] to him that he ran off yeah it's
some funny [ __ ] dude I was like man
that's a very get ol asian guy that
doesn't look ghetto at all oh you don't
think he does your math homework yeah he
looks like
duuude me a [ __ ] study partner
[Laughter]
[Music]